I didn't mean you don't know the X in
your eyes hi my name is Lucy Liang
Lucy Liang is a former prosecutor for
the Manhattan DA's office and current
executive director of the Institute for
innovation in prosecution today I'll be
breaking down clips from movies and film
about the courtroom pleading the fifth
The Good Wife roll clip did you and mr.
Kimball travel to Washington DC I refuse
to answer on the grounds that it may
incriminate me you're pleading the fifth
the Fifth Amendment says that no one can
be forced to say something against their
own self-interests are you sure that's
what you want to do either lawyers nor
judges can compel people to violate that
right yes yes I want to make sure I
understand what you're saying the judge
is out of line and continuing to
question this witness your beliefs is
not your place to ask my witness after
she invokes the fifth and the lawyer is
right to oppose the judge you are
piercing the Fifth Amendment I shut up I
don't know what I would do if a judge
told me to shut up
no sir especially when I was legally in
the rice Cuse me I will not shut up
objections how to get away with murder
explain why your eviction suit against
miss Morelli was dropped despite her
inability to pay is it because her loss
rent money was nothing compared to the
millions you made once miss Stanley was
out of your way feel her she's making a
strong point you do not have the time to
answer for who bore the real cost of
your developing search the judge has to
rule on the objections and she should
know to stop talking when she hears an
objection and wait for the judge to rule
the thousands who were displaced in the
name of lightning your caucus teacher
continuing after a judge has asked you
to stop is very bad practice please Your
Honor objections since you d'lai through
your teeth a better in any way wouldn't
you objection mr. Evans isn't it true
that your objection its rule of trial
practice 101 that when a lawyer objects
the other lawyer waits and lets the
judge rule on the objection I just
caught you in a lie objection your honor
mr. Evans my next move is gonna be
protections are being raised repeatedly
and the judge doesn't rule on it at all
Danny Griffith to the stand and she's
gonna testify that you lied to her for
years
objection the most common objections are
hearsay objection badgering rarely hear
a badger
the witness objection he's also gonna
say that you were jealous of his mind
Your Honor let me rephrase instead of
ruling on the record the judge gives her
a kind of hand gesture it does has to
rule on the objection otherwise there's
a record that there's been an objection
and no rule objection objection
objection that's what the judge is
supposed to do mr. Specter is within his
rights in the presence of royalty
continuance liar liar
how we doing this morning counsel
continuance a continuance is just an
adjournment so asking for a delay by a
day or more this case has already been
delayed realize that your honor but I
would really really really like
continuance he's asking for the
continuance because there's something
impeding him from the ability to do his
job now I have to hear good cause
counsel it's pretty accurate actually
that he'd be asked to show good cause
but he shouldn't be lying in furtherance
of his job so he shouldn't get the
continuance but she doesn't motion for
continuance denied there is a lot more
gavel banging in TV and film than there
is in real life in fact I can't say I've
ever had a judge bangs gavel at me
defendant testifying law and order
so whoever actually pulled the trigger
would be the true slave to Allah and
should be honored is that correct
just like
you're both enemies pretty sloppy
defendants only testify on their own
behalf in the minority of cases although
they absolutely have the right to you
keep denying it is that because you're
scared to accept those consequences the
prosecutor here is cross-examining the
defendant and it's fairly true to life
to how it would happen she was killed
her unborn child where there was an
outburst on the stand from a defendant
or anyone else's choices we breathe in
all likelihood the judge would intervene
and tell the witness to manage their
temper and probably strike the outbursts
from the record
for a classic witness outburst let's
look at legally one you however had time
to hide the gun didn't you techne after
you shot your father I didn't mean to
shoot him through the door Oh excellent
cross-examination by miss woods my god
she's asking leading questions didn't
you check me although her questions are
appropriately leaning wouldn't you have
heard the gunshot
and if in fact you had heard the gunshot
their compound there's a lot of
questions in one question you however
had time to hide the gun didn't you
techne after you shot your father I were
the prosecutor I would have objected to
those compound questions wouldn't
somebody who's had safe right here she's
talking directly to the jury and that is
not allowed you however had time to hide
the gun she actually manages to break
the witness I didn't mean to shoot I've
never seen that happen
[Music]
the classic witness outburst a few good
men you don't have to answer that
question I'll answer the question you
want answers I think I'm entitled you
want the truth you can't handle the
truth the rules in court-martial
proceedings are different from the rules
in a standard criminal courtroom but
it's unusual for a judge to allow an
exchange between a lawyer and a witness
to escalate to this level I don't give a
damn if you judge rules that a witness
doesn't have to answer a question don't
have to answer that question the witness
shouldn't answer the question I'll
answer the question but I can't argue
with this it's one of the great
courtroom scenes of all time protesting
the verdict the practice we find the
defendant edward wicks not guilty it's
hard for any lawyer to lose a case
that's Hance but this is above and
beyond what do you like the color of mr.
Donald's time gamble should not have
reacted that way in front of the jury
save it for when you get back to your
office
aren't you unemployed brain-dead idiots
in addition to possibly being held in
contempt she could face ethical
sanctions from the bar potentially lose
her job I don't care judge that's it
calendar call Roman Jay Israel Esquire
what do you have one number 32 thanks
Ann Bailey
this is a very realistic scene of a
routine calendar call when a judge has a
lot of cases on that are all in a
different posture the prosecutor is
there with a banker's box full of Case
Files which is very common and she's
going to be reading from the materials
with respect to each one of those cases
five years that's as low as the people
will go
his name is Langston he's a high school
junior in good standing many defense
lawyers would use the kind of mitigating
circumstances that mr. Israel sets out
in trying to persuade a prosecutor to
make a lower offer he is one Pryor minor
offense each one of us is greater than
the worst thing we've ever done I've
never heard music in the background when
they do it but otherwise it's very true
to live team Valve's Hollywood loves to
take a moral stance in a situation like
this and so defense lawyers we just get
it over with and shoot them that's the
offer
it's common for lawyers to negotiate a
disposition during down time in court in
situations like that talk to your
clients and the only uncommon thing my
conviction rates hundred percent is the
prosecutor referring to her conviction
rate which is just tacky effect
approaching the bench philadelphia do
you approach the bench wistfully
a lawyer cannot approach the bench ex
parte which means without the other
lawyer everybody in this courtroom
just thinking about sexual orientation
this is a great film but this part is
just not realistic explain this to me
like I'm a two-year-old the point I'm
approaching the bench is so that the
rest of the courtroom doesn't hear you
and you're speaking directly to the
judge let's talk about what this case is
really all about so this is inaccurate
first but the other lawyer isn't there
and second that everyone in the
courtroom can hear our loathing our fear
again with the poetic music somewheres
might hear it in their head when they're
talking but it's never happened to me
expert witness my cousin Vinnie this
witness is an expert in the field of
automobiles and is being called to rebut
the testimony of George Willborn an
expert witness as compared to a fact
witness what way are you qualified as a
witness who is permitted based on their
expertise to testify about their opinion
rather than things that are simply facts
I'd like to whadya this witness is to
the extent of her expertise to water an
expert witness about their qualification
to be certified as an expert I would ask
them questions about their background
what would the correct ignition timing
be on a 1955 Bel Air Chevrolet they
wouldn't pose a hypothetical like the
lawyer does here with the 327 cubic inch
engine to approach the witness stand a
lawyer has to ask the judges permission
first question it has to be for a good
reason like to show them a piece of
evidence or have them point to something
does that mean that you can't answer
this prosecutor is getting a bit out of
line he's getting in her face nobody
could answer that question speaking
aggressively towards her you don't know
the answer any answer a hypothetical
question to be 20:17 come out 262 and it
wasn't offered in the Bel Air with a
four-barrel carb till 64 instead of a
question about her expertise that's
inappropriate
well she's acceptable courtroom
demonstration to kill a mockingbird Tom
would you catch this please you can't
use the body of someone who is not on
the stand as a demonstration in court
this is are you please catch it with
your left hand
I can't use my left hand at all that's
not how the lawyer would make the point
that the defendant can't use his left
hand I got it caught in a cotton gin
when I was 12 years old you would have
had to call the defendant to the stand
to testify about it or call a doctor or
someone else who had first-hand
experience about the defendants
disability oh my muscles were told when
a witness is on the stand you are only
supposed to be questioning that witness
not the defendant or anyone else in the
courtroom I'm losing my memory
Atticus Finch is a hero amongst American
lawyers but he just doesn't get it quite
right this time sure hostile witness the
dark knight someone must have stepped up
to run the so-called family could you
identify him for us please
it was me when your own witness
unexpectedly contradicts your case it
was me then you can ask for permission
to treat them as hostile permission to
treat the witness as hostile this is a
pretty accurate depiction of the hostile
witness Rostow up until when he pulls
the gun and that the lawyer punches in
courthouses have metal detectors you
can't bring guns into the courtroom
unless they're evidence violent witness
primal fear he put you in front of a
camera he made you take off your clothes
and you don't think that that's another
side no you know what I would do if
someone did that to me I would kill a
moment she's making it about herself I
would have objected I wouldn't hesitate
lawyers aren't allowed to talk about
themselves while they're cross-examining
a witness I would stab him 78 times with
a butcher knife I would have objected
right there I would chop off his fingers
the judge would have interrupted her as
soon as she started to hypothesize about
what she would do I would slash his
throat open a judge would ask the court
officers to intervene as soon as it
looked like things were getting violent
I swear to god this is a terrifying
movie and Laura Linney's character is
way out of line but that's me sometimes
lawyers do try to agitate a witness in
order to get a reaction from them
further questions your honor
where the hell do you think you're going
which seems to be what she's trying to
do here and actually she does
it's rare for a witness or defendant to
get violent but it does happen and
that's why there are armed court
officers in every courtroom for criminal
trials character witness Big Daddy
Koufax is a good egg he was nice to that
kid mr. Koufax is a really cool guy but
he fights like a girl under the rules of
evidence a character witness can only
testify about something that's at issue
wish my dad was as cool as him so where
the issue is whether or not he's a good
dad they could testify about his
reputation as a good dad in the
community but they can't testify in
general about whether he's cool mr.
Koufax is a really cool guy I can't go
off topic you see my dad was a military
man I'd rather live out on the streets
than under his freaky-ass rules and also
the plaintiff should definitely not be
bribing the witness with McDonald's if
OJ can get away with murder
why can't Sonny have his kid jury
selection the devil's advocate let's get
rid of number four six and I'd say blues
number 12 except the prosecutor is gonna
up and do it for both sides have a
set number of peremptory challenges they
can use to strike potential jurors six
you're kidding right
she's been first choice they can both
agree to strike anyone and that doesn't
count against them and no one can strike
a juror on the base of a protected
category like race gender ethnicity or
sexual orientation but beyond that it's
no-holds-barred she wants on this jury
somebody heard her and she wants revenge
lawyers definitely try to psychoanalyze
potential jurors based on what they're
wearing and the way they comport
themselves
we're often pretty wrong how the hell do
you know that in my experience most of
the time people are trying to get out of
jury duty so I'm not sure how he thinks
he can tell that she wants to be on the
jury I don't know people have all kinds
of funny superstitions about who they
won't let on jury none of this is based
on science it's all basically guesswork
and the bottom line is that you want a
jury who can be fair all right here's
the deal I lose with you a jury you do
the explaining here's another example of
jury selection the Rainmaker did you mr.
Porto or did you not have a phone
conversation a few days ago with mr.
Rudy Baylor hell no I thought you gonna
give me
this is an example of our dear the
lawyers questioning the jury about their
ability to serve don't call me a lot
there's an awful lot of jumping over the
rail that seems to happen in film and TV
I've never seen it happen in their life
when something happens that can taint
the whole jury pool often a lawyer will
make an application to have the whole
pool dismissed and a new pool abroad
I'll dismiss a table here the judge
probably would have granted that
application denied film and TV love to
show jury selection but painted frankly
most lawyers hate us shoo little thing
the judge sang out of order from justice
for all something I judge would
typically call for order in the court in
a situation like that generally much
earlier kind of language that he uses is
totally inappropriate and then he turns
on his own clients my lawyer is
undermining his ethical obligation so
your honor Hollywood loves to show
emotional outbursts from lawyers these
are pretty uncommon we do our best to
control them we're gonna be seeing a lot
of them today though removing the
witness from daredevil I know what I did
I know who I am and he's come back any
any lowlife any maggot pieces did I put
down a judgement reprimand any lawyer or
witness who used bad language in the
courtroom I did it because I thought
most lawyers would work closely with the
defendant before he took the stand in
order to guard against those kind of
emotional outbursts it's make bad
Punisher
court officers are trained to respond to
a judge's orders immediately here the
court officers do take him out as soon
as the judge instructs them to most
judges would respond more quickly to
have that defendant removed from the
courtroom that kind of scene is fairly
uncommon settlement a civil action you
can pee
the jury has been impaneled and opening
statements are about to begin but the
lawyer sees the effect that seeing the
plaintiff is having on one of the jurors
and so that leads him to negotiate it's
very common that plea negotiations would
continue through a trial like this plea
negotiations have to happen outside the
awareness of the jury so if the jury
were in the box like this and the
parties were trying to negotiate
post-its is exactly how they would do it
jan schlichtmann for Paul Kearney Kevin
Conway for mr. Carney Your Honor I'd
start sweating too if I saw a juror
respond like this it is far more likely
for both criminal and civil cases to be
resolved with a plea or settlement
disposition parties involved to the
green to acetylene going through to the
conclusion of a trial courtroom attire
the Simpsons I rest my case the phrase I
rest my case
is commonly used one mr. Hutz do you
know you're not wearing any pants we
usually wear pants to work the formality
of courtroom attire has decreased in
recent years right but not quite to that
level that's why you're the judge and
I'm the law talking guy
the lawyer witness stripping Franklin
and bash and how exactly did you book
the mattress masters at my age injection
Your Honor
she's just roving to my knowledge
there's nothing in the rules of evidence
that says a witness can't take their
clothes off the client wanted a model
who could demand attempts Your Honor but
it's against all rules of courtroom
decorum who's Spencer where's advised
witnesses to behave respectfully towards
the court including dressing
appropriately for choirs refrain from
taking off your glass and not undressing
in court delicious of all of the
unrealistic things in this scene skews
the most unrealistic is when the lawyer
tells the witness to ignore that you
just tell you it is to disregard my
order that should never happen
justice isn't why this is so dumb
justice is all
let's focus on what she had to say um I
didn't get it there was a request for
read back again I was distracted this
sonographer really dropped the ball on
her job if we were all distracted by
miss Spencer in court what about the
people operating heavy machinery on
Sunset Boulevard this is made for TV
alone film and TV love this where
something happens in the courtroom and
then the lawyer uses it to prove their
case distracted that's not a real thing
only things are in evidence get to be
used to further an argument like that
ever scares us applause in the gallery
change lighting Walter Collins was
brutally murdered that correct captain
when a lawyer is questioning about
something as dramatic as that everyone
in the courtroom can feel the tenseness
of the situation yes it is the lawyers
the jury the audience everyone no
further questions in the modern day
applause is not allowed in the courtroom
but before we had courtroom scenes on
television and film people would go to
court to watch proceedings as part of
their entertainment and during that time
sometimes there would be applause in the
courtroom just like that contempt of
court serial mom one beer with lunch is
hardly drinking did you see that she
just said you to me the lawyers
antagonizing the witness so if the judge
saw that she would have been reprimanded
let the record show I am merely stating
again it's all about the record so it's
a stenographer didn't hear it it's like
it didn't happen are you insane
in Hollywood courtroom scenes are so
emotional people are guilty of that
judges are threatening to hold people in
contempt all the time
in reality I think I've probably only
seen it happen once or twice midnight
deadline Night Court
unfortunately word got out that anyone
not arraigned before midnight was set
free Wow
look at her hair we were so close that's
it we're finished
no we're not hold on Night Court
arraignments really happen in New York
City and all over the country prejudice
they tend to be very busy and fast-paced
but not this fast-paced
no arraignment is the first time that
someone who's charged with a crime
here's the charges read formally against
them York State New York violation 2 3 1
sometimes it happens in Night Court you
have to drive the vehicle come when
someone gets arraigned their lawyer says
waive the reading not the rights and
what happened in that case the defendant
didn't want to waive the reading so
that's why he was forced to read them
all out defendant representing himself
law abiding citizen and you've waived
your right to counsel correct yes sir
you sure you want to do that defendant
has an absolute right to represent
himself in court usually a defendant is
assigned backup counsel who actually has
legal training I find it highly
prejudicial to keep me detained without
bail when a defendant is representing
himself he's granted more leeway than
Alerus in terms of editorializing about
what he thinks is happening in the
courtroom the prosecution has not
presented one single piece of evidence
against me he's advocating for himself
and he's entitled to do that it's a
slippery slope Your Honor it's not
inappropriate and I think it's fairly
realistic I am actually inclined to
agree with you mr. Shelton thank you
indicted a dog from Perry Mason present
or not a man is still responsible for
what his dog does not criminally mr.
Wright that depends upon a number of
things perhaps the proper Criminal
Procedure would have been an indictment
of the dog council was joking of course
not at all
here the argument is about whether the
person can be charged for something that
an animal did a variety of animals have
been accused legally indicted and tried
in the past in the modern day animals
can't be indicted in charge the last
being a cow in 1740 however animals can
be considered dangerous instruments for
the purposes of a person committing an
assault since this is the 20th and not
the 15th century I'm going to rule that
the complaint is sufficient setting bail
fifty Shades freed does your client deny
forcing entry into this penthouse he
does not your honor however my client
dearly wanted to confront the parties
responsible for destroying his career I
think he wanted to do more than confront
them counselor
however given his clean record the court
will grant bail the basic options when a
judge is making a decision about bail
are releasing someone on their own
reconnaissance which means counting on
them to return on their own free will
setting bail which means determing an
amount of collateral that they will give
over and that is likely to ensure that
they return and remanding them which
means that no amount of money or
collateral will allow them to be
released while the charges are pending
set at $500,000 $500,000 bail is not
unheard of depending on the gravity of
the charges the defendants criminal
history their community ties and their
access your honor
next case very often it has a result of
meaning that someone can't make the bail
and therefore stays in custody read-back
intolerable cruelty because there's be
if they want some bones where were we
you want some bones does Elvita want
some bones this is called read-back
where a lawyer doesn't hear or loses
track of what the response has been they
can ask the stenographer back from the
transcription does anyone any bones read
back can happen during the child for a
lawyer or a jury can ask for read back
during their deliberations if there's
something they don't remember hard
crunchy bones right what's not accurate
is that a dog would be in the courtroom
on the stand with a witness unless it
was a therapy dog
how can she she should surprise witness
the good fight thank you for testifying
on such short notice miss Lockhart I
didn't have much choice I was subpoenaed
Your Honor again this is prosecution by
ambush we are not prepared for this
surprise witness that's just how that
would happen the prosecution has to
disclose their witnesses in advance of
trial to permit the defense to
appropriately prepare yes and as I
you will have time if you need it please
continue when something changes and her
new witness comes to light the
prosecutor might be permitted to call
that witness but as the judge promises
here the defense would then be granted
plenty of time to be able to prepare to
cross-examine that new witness yes
and quite well Miranda rights Madea Goes
to Jail apparently your honor our
officers forgot to mirandize her I was
waiting for Miranda to coming in nobody
came and I was waiting for it that's
right ain't nobody Miranda me Miranda
wasn't even in the room oh no excuse me
Miranda is the case that holds that
officers have to read a defendant their
rights before questioning that this is
ridiculous what they're referring to
here is that Madea made a statement to
police officers and she did it without
having been first read her Miranda
warnings you forgot to mirandize that a
woman got the strength any man when that
happens the statement that's made gets
suppressed as evidence which means it
can't be used against the defendant I've
got to let you go but it's not the case
that the defendant then just gets like a
conference and the judge's chambers the
verdict all I want on this trial was a
fair shake okay push me into court five
days early I lose my star witness and I
can't get a continuance and I don't care
I'm going up there I'm gonna try it I'm
gonna let the jury decide it's a TV and
film trope that judges and lawyers are
combative with each other they told me
about you in general we're all
professionals and we try to maintain
standards of professionalism and decorum
so you're a hard-ass you're a defendants
judge I don't care
seems like bad strategy to be leveling
personal accusations at the judge while
he has a case pending in front of him I
said the hell with it out with it
dismissing a case Miracle on 34th Street
if the government of the United States
can issue its currency barring a
declaration of trust in God than the
state of New York can accept and
acknowledge that Santa Claus does exist
and he exists in the purse
no tell my kids but I don't think the
existence of Santa Claus would stand up
in court again with the gavel this is in
New York and I haven't seen a judge in
this courthouse do that summation or
closing statement the night of what I
normally do is plea my clients out
because 95 percent of the time they did
what they were charged with I'm just
looking at them so I tell them don't be
stupid take the deal summations can only
be about the facts that are in evidence
it's what we think anything about the
lawyers personal contact with the
defendant with the witnesses or their
experience in general is totally outside
the bounds of appropriate summation the
first time I saw Nast
he was sitting alone in a holding cell
at the 21st precinct objection also not
in evidence I didn't see what I see in
my other clients John Turturro this is
not about you what we don't have proof
of is who committed the crime he's been
charged with that last part of the
summation where he's talking about the
facts that are in evidence the
circumstance and speculation that is the
purpose of summation yeah that term a
lot what does it really mean that for
another example of summation let's watch
a time to kill I'm gonna ask you all to
close your eyes this is a story about a
little girl I want you to picture this
little girl two men jumped out and
grabbed her they dragged her into a
nearby field raping her this is really
the appropriate time for a lawyer to get
theatrical on summation and that's
exactly what he does here I want you to
picture a little barrel he lays out his
view of the facts of the case and then
makes a powerful argument about bias now
imagine she's white this is exactly the
appropriate use of a summation although
it's awfully hard to watch the defense
restroom conclusion at the end of the
day I don't expect actors and directors
to get every detail right I understand
that writers like to make courtroom
scenes seem more dramatic than they
really are but
they get it wrong and they're pretty fun
to watch
[Music]